well welcome everybody we've
traditionally I've done a little bit of
a summary just to get things going sort
of what we did over the last few years
last big releases I figured I would
start off with one of those try to keep
it short and then we open up to
questions and we have representatives
here from all kinds of areas I represent
algorithm R&D which we'll see shortly
what that means tom sort of systems
programming compilation and and general
sort of system features Bochco the cloud
cloud Mathematica and volts the front
end and a notebook interface and we have
Arnout which represents you know it's
good representative for a pre-release
programs
QA and also a bit of systems programming
so I guess all right so let's get going
the our releases are big and tend to get
bigger over time as we expand to cover
more areas to build this language that
in effect is trying to be able to
express and discuss and talk about all
topics in life right that's the small
ambitious so we did and last year when
we met here we were sort of at the final
stages of wrapping up 12 oh it didn't
actually come out until April in that
time you know we spent a couple of
months building these what we call
marketing pages 248 marketing pages
somewhere around 20 examples on each
they tried to summarize and exemplify
what's in that release which includes
eleven one two three and the gap between
11:30 and 12:00 if you spend five
minutes per page there's about four
hours to cover it and it it's it's solid
you know if it's the live presentations
they take a you know about an hour we've
been doing two per week they are going
to finish up in November
we're still from April we've been doing
these presentations to a week we hope to
finish up in November I was gonna do if
we go to those pages those are actually
really good pages if we we put a lot of
work into it to build those pages
and to just give you a little bit of a
summary here it's big enough so
classical areas that we work in symbolic
numeric computation
there's the steady progress of making
everything better faster so things that
become better is like limit now do
multivariate limits they're stronger and
things like that and derivative for
symbolic and asymptotics is a new way of
computing it's a third mode of computing
in parallel to symbolic computing the
merit computing asymptotic computing
we're still rolling out in 12:1 we'll
get more features like asymptotic
product and the general overall
asymptotic that can give you things like
asymptotic inverse Laplace transforms
and and asymptotic series coefficients
things like that optimization big story
there is the the old the old from the
70s classification and eighties
classification there's linear
optimization and as nonlinear
optimization that turned out to be kind
of largely wrong it's really convex and
non convex you know so the easy problems
the ones that you can solve fast robust
or convex the ones that you can't are
not come X now everything every time you
have a classification this has known
something you know it's stupid so this
is just the beginning it's just a bigger
easy set the the fact that it has none
in its name means that it needs a lot
more classification and stratification
nonlinear finite elements so that that
sort of completes the round out for
being able to model physical systems
with nonlinear partial differential
equations what we're working on now
which you've seen a little bit of is a
symbolic modeling language not
for 12-1 but we hope to bring you sort
of a high level symbolic modeling
language for PDEs because we have really
powerful solvers but it's really hard to
actually feed them with models so we got
to make that simpler
that's a nice problem we have that
problem in many places visualization and
graphics lots of area so there's things
that we call out like visualizing the
complex domain as you've seen and this
isn't one or the first areas where we
use a two-dimensional color function so
a color function that goes in in both is
often try to represent both the face of
the complex number and the magnitude so
there's a two dimensions right so how do
you do that well you map them to maybe
hue and luminosity you know their
various mappings but there's not one
example that that continues with 12 one
has more complex visualization that sort
of gives you a complete stack for for
complex what we can do it for reals
Geographic steady progress vectors and
in 12-1 there's more there is density in
contour plots over over geographic
regions labeling is this thing that
seems simple on the surface but it's
surprisingly challenging and we keep
rolling out bits of it and more to come
and in the core where you can see the
beginnings of new domains like scaling
functions everywhere that's one that's
been rolling out you've seen it rolling
out for a long time there's still more
to come the beginnings of a new program
which is rolling out support for
uncertainty in our visualization
functions now think about 150 biz
functions how do you represent
uncertainty in all of them
well we haven't thought that all through
yet but we're gonna roll it out as we
move forward because uncertainty is
something that's gonna go in kind of
deep and big in the language and also
the beginnings of other things like
multi-panel plots there's much more to
come with multi panel including more in
12:1 geometry and geography the the
there it is so there's a lot of headroom
here for for everything both in geometry
and geography so big big pieces of
progress here for for geometry in
workflows and robustness the reagent
wrapper is the thing that kind of
simplifies all workflows for for
geometry so it was a big deal there's
lots of improvements in little filling
functionality and making the whole
framework more robust and it's still a
little bit more to come and then we're
gonna be ready to take next big jumps in
geometry once once those are the part of
that this is to do properly to really do
polygons in polyhedra the polygons
there's a zillion definitions like every
polygon definition agrees if it's a if
it's a boundary curve that doesn't
intersect when you have multiple
boundary curves survey self intersecting
boundary curves or both there is a
zillion definition of what is a polygon
now the same happens when you have
polyhedron where you have a boundary
surface now when the boundary surface
doesn't insect where you don't have
multiple boundary surface there's pretty
much just one definition when there are
many of them like for polygons there's a
zillion definitions so we sorted all
that out that's released there's
actually a little bit more to come for
polyhedra to complete that out you will
see that next that's a that's an
important base for geometry and a
question that's come up many times like
when you're gonna have Voronoi for 3d
well the Voronoi for 3d needs polyhedral
cells now we have polyhedra for the
first time as a primitive so now we can
have it that's coming out soon
synthetic geometry you guys have seen
this Euclidean geometry I personally
don't think that this is a useful topic
but because I don't see it being applied
to anything but many people do and
they're really passionate about it and
so it's so it's it's been you know been
picked up and it's it's it's used a lot
that's great
but it's one of those things that could
be eliminated from curricula okay
science Cisco we uncertainties is is a
new thing so uncertainty is the
stochastic uncertainty is basically a
normally distributed variable with kind
of a tight bound and it's it's
represented as around we've seen the
beginnings of this there's much more to
come and it's it's in principle
something that will take probably a
decade to fully support so here is the
thing like if you have uncertainty going
in into your weather predictions you
want a sort of the data for your weather
model you want the uncertainty to come
out in your predictions and you expect
that right so then you can think about
that in the in the Mathematica system
every solver in the whole system now
needs to be reworked sorry that takes a
little time if you're going to sort of
have uncertainty in and uncertainty out
so but that's that is a big deal because
you kind of want to qualify qualify that
probability statistics kind of a little
intermediate year intermediate release
with random matrices lots of the robust
descriptive statistics and things like
that what you've seen previews of in
this conference is spatial statistics
coming out next we didn't talk about
much of that there's a lot of finance
time series and other things on its way
in that space to graph the networks
again that's like we're not in an
intense phase of graph in networks
development but it's still the best in
the world and we're gonna keep on
rolling out and keeping it at that level
so that there will be still quite a lot
of things but as I said that framework
is the best in the world so it is data
import/export that's you know so for
twelve one of the data side basically
got clean up its fastest completes big
topics are everyday things like
spreadsheets with partial access modern
versions
and and performance improvements but
other things that are very complex data
formats like HD F which wasn't properly
supported all the way out to its it's
it's full degree all of that got done
and finished off in 12 I think that
there the tabular data side is now I
would say very complete you know as far
as a ghost there's always more you know
we could decide whether we should do to
support those but the ones that we are
there it's at the very core it's it's
it's all that it's fast image and audio
so the big big theme for both of these
things is to utilize machine learning to
get sort of these super functions to get
high level capabilities so identify cats
you know important topics or meows in
speech which is what we now do in audio
but more seriously there's sort of
speech recognition and and and on all of
these things these high-level functions
that are their old kind of machine
learning based and machine learning but
I really sort of brought a revolution to
those kinds of that kind of
functionality and so they're topically
there's machine learning specifically so
the whole machine learning framework has
been optimized and so for you guys to do
anything machine learning in these
domains - is very easy because all those
frameworks are really well done done for
that there's one vertical which is
microscopy and you will see more of
these for this one and and other
verticals for from from image processing
going forward like astronomy and
medicine you know and so on
well machine learning steady progress
everything so the the the neural network
framework sort of got a big boost in the
12 cycle and so one thing is to solve to
support all these different kinds of
modeling framework like which which is
supported by all the layers that are
there in the neural network frameworks
but also the efficiency of the whole
frameworks to support multiple GPU to
support half precision computation so
normally Buddhists sneeze at anything
less than double in Mathematica well the
machine learning guys they not only do
sort of floats which is not double they
do halves like so so so getting
performance there is a big deal and
multiple GPUs have precision everything
to get the performance and also you've
seen in this conference the ability to
upload and use AWS to train because
you're unlikely to have you know they're
really big sort of GPUs set up that you
kind of often need for these big
training jobs so all of that is is in
place or getting in place and you can
see 12-1 is sort of completing out that
cycle around out that cycle largely on
the high-level side which is machine
learning the big thing there is learn
distribution which allows you once you
have a distribution of data you can say
what's not in the data what's an outlier
to data that's the big thing
you can also synthesize missing values
because if it's gonna follow the same
distribution just generate a random
instance from that distribution and
that's you fill it in and then the core
three application domains image and
audio that we talked about but also
natural language text processing those
are the three killer apps currently for
machine learning more to come but those
are the ones for now and I'm gonna sort
of teeter out here when we get to the
bottom there's much more interesting
things to say about everything here the
last thing here that the Wolfram
knowledge base it's not per se a new
knowledge base but it's documented which
means it's discoverable in a new way and
I think that's that's really important
I'm not part of developing this and I've
been hounding these guys for years it's
like gotta give us a way to discover
what's mysteriously in this knowledge
base so and there it is it's great
okay and I apologize for everything I
didn't cover but that's a that's a
little bit of a round out to what's
happened in 12